This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全但却很坦诚的对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听“以防万一”，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在 IHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听《2%》。即数字 2%，在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year,
在 IHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重要时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a wild year.
盘点当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有比这更疯狂的年份了。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, you know the drill. It is so great to have you here back for not only another episode, but a very, very, very special episode. This is my 100th episode of the Psychology of Your 20s, and I'm kind of shook. I cannot believe that I've made a hundred of these episodes. It's just so,
我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，你知道规矩的。非常高兴你能回来，不仅是为了收听另一期节目，而且是非常非常非常特别的一期节目。这是我的《你二十岁的心理学》第一百期节目，我整个人都有点震惊了。我简直不敢相信我已经制作了一百期这样的节目。这对我来说简直是……
insane to me that like this little tiny podcast that I started in back in when I was at uni really back in like my sharehouse in Canberra is you know my job now is like the thing that I love the most is the thing that I put so much time and attention to and there are so many of you amazing listeners out there who tune in every single week and who send me the most kind heartfelt lovely messages and I'm just so grateful and glad that this content has resonated with so many people. It's such like an incredible milestone to me like a hundred episodes. I did not think that I was going to make 100 episodes, let alone make 50 when I first started. It was just like a fun little hobby for me to like discuss
太疯狂了，就像这个我当年还在上大学时，真的就像是在堪培拉我的合租房里开始的这个小小播客，你知道的，现在成了我的工作，就像是我最热爱的事情，是我倾注了大量时间和精力的事，有那么多优秀的听众每周都在收听，并给我发来最善良、最由衷、最可爱的私信，我真的非常感激，也非常高兴这个内容能够引起这么多人的共鸣。对我来说，一百期节目是一个如此不可思议的里程碑。刚开始的时候，我根本没想过自己能做满一百期，更不用说五十期了。当时这对我来说只是一个小小的有趣爱好，用来讨论……
my favorite topics in psychology and what I was thinking about and what my friends were thinking about and it's really come so far. So I just want to say from the bottom of my heart, thank you, thank you, thank you for listening, for supporting this show, for caring what I have to say. That's like, I think, the most bizarre part of it. I really, really appreciate it. And kind of in honor of that milestone, I thought that I'd do something a little bit different. So regularly scheduled content will resume, obviously, on Friday. But there are so many questions that I regularly get from people. So many people follow me on Instagram and send me DMs and want advice and want to know more
我最喜欢的心理学话题，以及我在想什么、我的朋友们在想什么，它真的已经走了这么远。所以，我只想从心底里说，谢谢你们，谢谢你们，谢谢你们的收听，谢谢你们支持这个节目，谢谢你们关心我要说的话。我觉得，这大概是最不可思议的部分了。我真的、真的很感激。为了纪念这个里程碑，我觉得应该做点不一样的事情。所以，常规安排的内容当然会在周五恢复。不过，大家经常会问我很多问题。很多人在 Instagram 上关注我，给我发私信，想要征求建议，想要了解更多……
about me. And I think that I've kind of like shied away from like talking about my like kind of breaking the fourth wall, right? And like talking about my experience actually making this show and what I've learned. And obviously I use like anecdotal pieces of my life throughout the show. but like I feel like I've never really sat down and been like, here's who I am, this is what I do, this is what my life is like. So I thought that in honor of 100 episodes, we would do that today. And I got all of your questions from Instagram. You guys sent through so many. So I really appreciate
关于我的事情。我觉得我一直有点回避谈论那些，像是打破第四堵墙的事情，对吧？比如谈论我实际制作这个节目的经历以及我学到了什么。当然，我在整个节目中都用到了我生活中的一些轶事片段，但我觉得我从来没有真正坐下来过，然后说：“这就是我，这就是我做的事，这就是我的生活。”所以我想，为了纪念一百期节目，我们今天就来聊聊这个。我收集了你们在 Instagram 上的所有问题。大家发来了超级多问题；所以非常感谢……
you taking the time to think of some amazing things to ask. And I want to sit down. I want to answer them. I want to give some advice and just kind of talk about what this, like, what this has been like also. It's also the two-year anniversary of the show as well. So I didn't even mention that. It's like 100 episodes and two-year anniversary. So, oh my God, got a two-year-old. I've got a little toddler now, a little toddler of a podcast. So so many amazing celebrations. And I really want to, Yeah, I really want to do something different this way you can sit down and kind of like have a chat. So that's what we're going to do in just a second. Alrighty, everyone.
你们花时间想出了一些非常棒的问题来问我。我想坐下来。我想回答这些问题。我想给出一些建议，顺便聊聊这个，也就是这段经历是怎么样的。这也正好是节目的两周年纪念日。所以我甚至都没提到这一点。这就好像是一百期节目加两周年纪念。哦天哪，我有一个两岁大的孩子了。我现在的播客就像个蹒跚学步的小 toddler（幼儿）了。所以有这么多值得庆祝的事，我真的很想，是的，我真的很想用这种方式做点不一样的，这样你们就可以坐下来，好好聊聊天。这就是我们接下来要做的。好了，各位。
Let's get into it. So the OG listeners of this show will remember that like when I first started, I was literally recording on my phone. Terrible idea, terrible audio quality in like the back of my car, in my sharehouse, like on my friend's floor. and a lot of like the content that I originally did was with my good friends. So if you go back and you go all the way back to the beginning, you'll see it's just like people that I knew at college, like people that I knew at university who I thought were really interesting and I would like bring them on for a chat. And it's like so bizarre now that like it's evolved into this like entirely new process, but I really think that what I've tried to, like, remain and, like, keep at its core
我们开始吧。节目的老听众会记得，当我刚开始做的时候，我真的是用手机在录音。这主意太糟糕了，音质差得要命，就在我车后座、合租房里，或者朋友的地板上。而且我最初创作的很多内容都是和我的好朋友一起录的。如果你回过头去看，一直看到最开始，你会发现这其实就是我在大学里认识的人，比如那些我认为非常有趣、我会邀请他们来聊天的大学同学。现在回想起来，它演变成这样一个全新的流程，真的是太不可思议了，但我真的认为我一直试图坚守和……
is, like, that authenticity, right? Like, no one writes my scripts for me. No one edits my episodes for me. I am still, to this day, sitting on the floor. I wish I'm going to post a photo. I'm sitting on the floor recording this with my laptop. And I really want to keep it that way. Like, I think that that is what really brings people in, but also what makes people in. But also what makes it fun for me that it is still this like really beautiful solitary but also like self-motivated and self-run activity one of the questions i got which i really loved is that you know obviously in two years it went from being like a hobby to obviously there's so many people who are listening to this like it's beyond insane to me like i don't even think i can comprehend it and someone asked me like
保持其核心的，正是那种真实性，对吧？没有人帮我写剧本。没有人帮我剪辑节目。直到今天，我依然坐在地板上。我真希望……我一会儿要发张照片。我正坐在地板上用笔记本电脑录音。我真的想保持这种状态。我觉得，这才是真正吸引人的地方，也是让我觉得有趣的地方，它仍然是一个非常美丽、孤独，但同时又是自我驱动和自我运营的活动。我收到的一个我很喜欢的问题是，你知道的，显然在两年的时间里，它从一个爱好变成了——显然有这么多人正在收听——这简直超出常理，我甚至觉得我都无法理解，有人问我……
what is the biggest lesson that you've learned? I think the biggest lesson that I've learned has to do with, like, authenticity and vulnerability. And that is that when you put yourself out there in a way, that is quite vulnerable. That is very, not unique, but I would say revealing, people really respond to that. I really thought that the interesting thing I think is that the topics that I thought, were going to bomb like the topics I thought no one would ever listen to I thought they were too private there was one on loneliness the recent episode I did on how I've been feeling ugly and
你学到的最大教训是什么？我觉得我学到的最大教训，跟真实性和脆弱感有关。那就是当你以某种方式展露真实的自我时，那种感觉是相当脆弱的。这虽说不上独一无二，但我会说这是极具启发性的，人们对此真的很有共鸣。我原以为——我觉得有趣的是——那些我以为会砸掉招牌的话题，比如那些我以为永远不会有人听的话题，我以为它们太私密了，其中有一个关于孤独的节目，我最近做的一期关于我如何觉得自己变丑的节目，以及……
this one on like situation chips those three episodes that I thought no one would be would want to listen to they were too private they were too vulnerable have been the ones that people come back to me time and time again and say like that really changed my outlook on life that was really important for me to hear. And I think that that really provided me with this sense of like, people are actually just looking for connection and people want someone to, I guess, be real. And hopefully that is what I continue to do. And I really want to keep doing that because I think there is so much content out there that is curated, that is edited, that is fake, that is produced to a point of it being completely unrelatable. And as much as that is entertaining and as much
这期关于“Situationship”（暧昧关系）的节目，我以为这三期节目根本不会有人想听，因为它们太私密了，太脆弱了，但它们反而是人们一次又一次回来对我说：“那期节目真的改变了我对生活的看法，听了那番话对我真的很重要。”我觉得这确实让我有一种感觉：人们其实只是在寻找连接，人们希望有人能够，我猜，展现真实的一面。希望这也是我一直在做的事情。我真的很想继续这样做，因为我觉得外面有太多经过策划、剪辑、虚假、甚至被制作得完全无法引起共鸣的内容。尽管这些内容很有娱乐性，尽管……
as like our brains love a good doom scroll on Instagram and love a little bit of social comparison, we really like kind of lost touch with what it means to just be having a human experience. And we've lost touch with what it means to be someone who is insecure and someone who has gone through it and someone who is in their 20s and just as confused as everyone else. So I do think like the biggest lesson I've learned is that when you put yourself out there, life will reward you and you will surprise yourself. Life will surprise you in a million ways, a million tiny different ways. Another lesson I've learned actually is how willing people are to share their stories with you. That has been such a beautiful surprise, the amount of people that even like come up to me on the street or
我们的大脑很喜欢在 Instagram 上刷那些让人焦虑的负面内容（doom scroll），也很喜欢进行一点社交比较，但我们确实有点失去了那种仅仅去体验人类经历的本真意义。我们失去了作为充满不安全感的人、经历过生活坎坷的人、以及身处二十岁却和所有人一样感到困惑的人的本真意义。所以我的确认为，我学到的最大教训就是，当你敞开心扉展现真实的自己时，生活会回报你，你会给自己带来惊喜。生活会以百万种方式、百万种微小不同的方式给你带来惊喜。我学到的另一个教训其实是，人们是多么乐意与你分享他们的故事。这真是一个美好的惊喜，有那么多甚至在街上认出我的人，或者……
people that I get DMs from who I think we're all just really seeking connection. And I think that was something I did know beforehand, but I've really learned that it runs so much deeper than I think a lot of us recognize. Like we all are just looking to connect on some very universal human level. So I would say that is the true, maybe it's the same lesson. Like one of the biggest lessons that I've learned from the show, the other one that I would like, it's kind of a piece of advice, kind of a lesson. is do not record on your phone.
给我发私信的人，让我觉得我们其实都在极力寻找连接。我想这正是我事先就知道的事，但我真正了解到的是，它比我们许多人意识到的要深刻得多。就像我们所有人其实都在寻找某种非常普世的人性层面上的连接。所以我要说，这是真正重要的，也许这就是同一个教训。我从这个节目中学到的最大教训之一，另一个我想说的是，既是一个建议，也是一个教训……那就是千万不要用手机录音。
Go on, if you want to be a podcaster, if, like, I think when I started, I really, like, kind of didn't really believe in myself and was just doing it for fun. You should really invest in yourself. If there's something you really want to do, go and actually buy the equipment. Like, I listen back to some of my early episodes, and, like, the episode that obviously gets the most listens is the one on imposter syndrome, which is my first ever episode. And it is, like, please do not listen to it. It is so poorly recorded.
去吧，如果你想成为一名播客创作者，如果，我觉得我刚开始的时候，其实并不是很相信自己，只是为了好玩才做的。你真的应该投资自己。如果你有什么非常想做的事，去把设备买下来。比如，我回听了自己早期的一些节目，显然获得最多收听量的那个节目是关于“冒名顶替综合征”的，那是我有生以来第一期节目。那感觉就像是，求求你们千万别听。录得太差了。
it is terrible. And I've like been tossing up like whether I just re-record it because it's often the first episode people listen to when they find my show or whether I just leave it up just to kind of show the process and the growth that we all go through. Like you're going to learn so many things by just doing. Oh my gosh. Actually maybe that's my biggest life lesson that I've learned from this. Like I think if we wait for everything to be perfect, we miss out on a lot of
简直糟糕透顶。我一直在纠结，我是该把它重新录一遍，因为这通常是人们发现我的节目时听的第一期节目，还是就把它留在那里，好用来展示我们所有人经历的过程和成长。你会通过不断实践学到很多东西。哦天哪。其实这也许才是我从中学到的最大生活教训。我觉得如果我们等待一切都完美了才行动，就会错过很多……
the learning opportunities and you can just learn on the way. Like this show has adapted and grown so much and developed, right? Like I started recording on my phone and then I started recording with like a microphone. I got off, I think like Amazon and then I finally like got a proper, like, you know, that's so boring, right. No one wants to hear that. But I think you will learn in anything that you do better by doing than by waiting. All right. So the next question that I got was what advice would you give to someone who wants to start a podcast, I get this question a lot. I would say, just do it, firstly. It doesn't matter if your first episode is terrible. What matters is that you are consistent and that you learn along the way. So I would say practical advice is to really invest in like a good
学习的机会，你完全可以在边做边学中成长。你看，这个节目已经适应、成长并发展了这么多，对吧？我一开始是用手机录音，然后开始用麦克风录音。我从，我想大概是从亚马逊上买的，然后我终于弄了一个像样的，你知道的，这太无聊了，对吧。没人想听这个。但我认为，你在做任何事情时，边做边学都比一味等待要学得更好。好的。那么我收到的下一个问题是，你会给想要做播客的人什么建议？我经常收到这个问题。我的回答是，首先，直接去做吧。你的第一集有多糟糕其实并不重要。重要的是你要保持连贯性，并且在过程中不断学习。所以我要给出的实用建议是，真的去投资一个好……
name, invest in like a good cover art. Like I didn't really think those things through it just kind of happened that, you know, they just worked for me. But if I was going to start it again, I would say really invest in a good piece of cover art, invest in a good name, have a strong theme or idea of what you want to talk about. And I would say make sure that it's unique to you. There's no point looking at what someone else is doing and trying to replicate that because I think that it's just not authentic. And you want actually find that you're motivated to do it. Like, if that's someone else's path, right? That's someone else's dream. And yes, we can have the same dreams, but you have to do your dreams in a different way. So I would say, if you are really
名字，投资一个好的封面设计。当时我并没有深思熟虑这些事情，只是顺其自然地觉得，你知道的，它们对我来说挺合适的。但如果让我重新开始，我会说一定要投资一个好看的封面，投资一个好名字，有一个强有力的主题或者你想讨论的想法。而且我要说，确保它是属于你独一无二的。看着别人的做法然后去盲目复制是没有意义的，因为我觉得那一点都不真实。而且你不会发现自己有动力去坚持做这件事。因为那是别人的道路，对吧？那是别人的梦想。是的，我们可以有相同的梦想，但你必须以不同的方式去实现你的梦想。所以我想说，如果你真的……
interested in, like, starting a podcast, really, like, sit down and think, like, what do I love to talk about? Not just what do I think I love to talk about? But, like, what would I sit down and talk about with my friends? That's why there's so many, like, amazing chatty guest series out there, because that's what people want to talk about and hear. They want to hear those intimate conversations, they want to be educated. And I think that also flips around to the people making the shows, like, what would you actually want to listen to? You should make content like that. Also, invest in a good microphone. Learned that the hard way. And don't be too preoccupy with social media. I don't know if many people listening to this know. I have a TikTok. It is embarrassing.
对创办一个播客感兴趣，真的，坐下来好好想想：我到底喜欢谈论什么？不仅仅是我以为自己喜欢谈论什么？而是，我会和朋友坐下来谈论什么？这就是为什么外面有那么多精彩的聊天式嘉宾访谈系列，因为那是人们想要谈论和倾听的内容。他们想听那些亲密的对话，他们想要获得教育。我觉得这也同样适用于做节目的创作者：你自己实际上想听什么？你就应该创作这样的内容。另外，投资一个好的麦克风。我可是吃一堑长一智。不要太过于沉迷于社交媒体。不知道听这个节目的有多少人知道。我有一个 TikTok。那简直太尴尬了。
I think it has like 200 followers because I like never advertise it. And I get like, 30 views because it just doesn't matter to me, right? Like, I know that I'm not like someone who excels at social media. I know that that's not what I do best. I just want to share knowledge and talk and really think deeply about things and share that on. So just know what you do best. Know what you're. And also, sorry, this is so rambly, but have a good sense of what you want out of this.
我想它大概只有 200 个粉丝，因为我从来不做宣传。我大概只有 30 的播放量，因为我根本不在乎，对吧？我知道我不是那种擅长搞社交媒体的人。我知道那不是我最擅长的。我只想分享知识、聊天、深入思考事物，并把它分享出去。所以，清楚自己最擅长什么。清楚你……还有，抱歉，我废话太多了，但你得清楚你到底想从中得到什么。
because if you're like, I want to be like a successful podcaster, I don't think that happens overnight and there's going to be a lot of like work that goes into it that I think a lot of people don't see. Like it is, it's a really fun hobby. It's a amazing thing to do. I would never discourage anyone from from doing it. But it is a lot of work. So like think about whether you're after an immediate reward or a long-term reward and whether it is particularly fulfilling. This next question, I love this again, is what is the favorite topic, my favorite topic that I've covered? I have so many, but I did, the recent episode I did on why I feel ugly was actually one that I really enjoyed doing. I think it was a lot more personal and a lot more
因为如果你抱着“我想成为一个成功的播客主”的心态，我觉得那不会一夜之间发生，而且这背后会有大量的工作，我想很多人并没有看到这一点。就像，这真的是一个非常有趣的爱好。这是一件很棒的事情。我绝不会劝阻任何人去做这件事。但这确实需要大量的工作。所以，想想你追求的是即时回报还是长期回报，以及它是否真的有成就感。下一个问题，我同样很喜欢，那就是你做过的主题里，最喜欢的是哪一个？我有太多喜欢的了，不过我最近做的那期关于“为什么我觉得自己变丑了”的节目，其实是我非常享受制作的一期。我觉得它更加个人化，也更加……
intimate. I did this episode on the psychology of the 9 to 5. I think it was like episode four with my best friend Erin. She actually inspires so much of the content that I speak on here. So much because she is, she needs to come on again. She is probably the most fascinating person you'll ever meet. She has the most amazing, well thought out opinions and just talking to her about our lives and our 20s and what we're both going through really inspires a lot of the content. So like the one that I, the other one that I can think of is the myth of the dream job that came from like a discussion with her. The psychology of Lucky Girl Syndrome that came from a discussion with her.
亲密。我做过一期关于“朝九晚五的心理学”的节目。我想那是第四集，和我的好闺蜜埃琳（Erin）一起录的。其实我在这里谈论的很多内容都灵感来源于她。真的有很多，因为她，她得再来做一次嘉宾。她可能是你这辈子能遇到的最迷人的人了。她有着最惊艳、最深思熟虑的见解，仅仅是和她聊聊我们的生活、我们的二十岁以及我们俩正在经历的事情，就激发了大量的内容灵感。所以，另一个我想到的就是“梦想工作的神话”，那也是从和她的讨论中产生的。“幸运女孩综合征的心理学”也是从和她的讨论中诞生的。
That's actually so interesting. I would say my favorite episodes are ones that have come out of chatting and really connecting. I think also this is quite a solitary activity. And when you get to sit down and really talk with someone and talk. through your ideas and explain the psychology with someone else. It feels a lot more grounded and a lot more well-rounded. So I would say those are my favorites. And then also, oh, how could I forget the episode with Chidera Egaru that I did at the start of the year? I can't remember what the title was. I think it's like parental wounds and dating men, something like that. But that episode, I love that
这其实挺有趣的。我想说，我最喜欢的节目都是那些在聊天和真正连接的过程中自然而然诞生出来的。我觉得这也是一个相当孤独的活动。当你能坐下来，真正和某人交谈，把……
episode. I actually regularly still listen to that episode, like once every month or couple of months. All right. Next question. Do you listen to your own advice? Yeah, and no. Yes and no. I think I cover a lot of topics that I personally need advice on and want to be able to do the research because there's something that I'm personally going through. so the recent episode on self-sabotage, that was something that I was really kind of thinking about in my own personal life and wanted to explore that. I think I do take my own advice because it is obviously everything that I produce is grounded in what I think and like and the evidence that I obviously acknowledge and know. The other day actually it was interesting. I was really struggling
那个节目。其实我到现在还是会定期重听那期节目，大概每个月或者几个月听一次。好的。下一个问题。你会听取你自己的建议吗？会，也不是。又会，又不会。我觉得我探讨了很多我自己也需要建议的主题，而且我想做研究，因为那正是我个人正在经历的事情。所以最近关于“自我破坏”的那期节目，正是我在自己的个人生活中认真思考并想要探索的事情。我想我确实会听取我自己的建议，因为我产出的所有内容显然都扎根于我的想法、喜好，以及我明显认可和了解的证据。前几天其实挺有趣的。我当时真的很挣扎……
with like confidence and I went back and I listened to my episode on self-confidence. confidence because I was like, who better to give me advice than me in some ways? Like, I'm going to trust my opinion, perhaps a lot better. Sometimes I do like to obviously listen to other people. There's this podcast called Date Yourself Instead. Love listening to that for like some solid advice. Sometimes you just need someone else to tell you what your deal is and to be honest with you in a way that you're perhaps not honest with yourself. But yeah, I would say yes and no. There are definitely things that I think we all still need to work on. I find it really fascinating when people are like, oh, like, you seem to have your life together. And I'm like, I absolutely do not have my life together. I'm trying. I'm aiming
关于自信心的问题，我回过头去听了我自己做的那期关于自信心的节目。因为我想，在某些方面，还有谁能比我自己给我更好的建议呢？比如，我会选择相信自己的意见，也许会好得多。有时我当然也喜欢听取别人的意见。有一个叫《约会你自己》（Date Yourself Instead）的播客。我很喜欢听那个来获取一些扎实的建议。有时你只是需要别人来指出你的问题所在，并以某种你可能对自己不够坦诚的方式对你实话实说。但话又说回来，我会说会也不是。确实有些事情我觉得我们所有人仍需努力。每当别人说“哦，天哪，你看起来把生活过得井井有条”时，我都觉得非常有意思，而我就会想：我的人生绝对没有井井有条。我在努力。我在朝着那个目标……
for it. But I just am really fascinated by how we can apply like the psychology to not only improve our lives, but I think also on a deeper level understand our lives a bit more. I think, self-improvement is this really interesting domain and, like, area where we think that everything needs to be directed towards being better and, you know, being good and excelling. Sometimes it's actually about sitting down and being like, I'm going to, I'm going to take time to think, and I'm going to really self-reflect and really do some of that hard work before I try so hard to shift everything around me and make my life perfect. I do think that an equal part of self-improvement is contemplation and reflection as it is action.
努力。但我只是对如何运用心理学不仅改善我们的生活，而且在更深层次上更多地理解我们的生活，感到非常着迷。我觉得，自我提升是一个非常有趣领域和方向，在这个领域里，我们总觉得一切都必须指向变得更好、变得优秀以及出类拔萃。但有时，这其实是关于静下心来告诉自己：“我要花时间去思考，我要在拼命试图改变周围的一切、把生活变得完美之前，进行真正的自我反思，做一些艰苦的内在工作。”我认为，自我提升中，沉思和反思与实际行动同等重要。
The next question, which I thought was really, really funny, but this passage just said, I want deeds on your love life. Okay. So it was actually really interesting because I met up with an old friend recently who knew me when I was in like a past relationship that I've spoken about on this show and he was like, oh, I listened to some of those episodes that were about that person. And I didn't know all these things like happened. And that kind of left me a little bit shook.
接下来的问题，我觉得非常非常有趣，这一段只写了一句：“我想看你感情生活的八卦。”好吧。其实这挺有意思的，因为我最近和一个老朋友聚会，他认识我时，我正处在一段我曾在节目中谈论过的过去恋情中，他说：“哦，我听了其中几期关于那个人的节目。我竟然不知道发生了所有这些事情。”这确实让我有点震惊。
It really did leave me questioning how much I should be sharing online about my dating life. Obviously, I have been quite open about past relationships. You know, I had my ex on the podcast. But it really does leave me thinking, like, I do think people can learn from my experiences because of their universal nature in that a lot of the things I think we all experience in our 20s. I'm also experiencing because I'm in my 20s and they're not regularly spoken about by people of this age to people of this age if that makes sense. But right now, I don't know what to say about my dating life right now. I would say I've worked through a lot of the stuff I just needed
它真的让我开始反思，我究竟应该在网上分享多少关于我约会生活的事情。显然，我对过去的恋情一直相当坦诚。你知道的，我还请我的前任上过播客。但这确实让我思考，我确实认为人们可以从我的经历中学习，因为这些经历具有普世性，其中许多事情我认为我们在二十岁时都会经历。我也在经历，因为我也正处于二十岁，而且这些事并不经常被这个年纪的人向这个年纪的人公开谈论，如果这说得通的话。但就目前而言，对于我现在的约会生活，我不知道该说些什么。我想说的是，我已经走出了许多我需要……
to work through, not only to do with like past partners, but also just in terms of my own insecurities. And I'm really happy. And I'm at a place of like such peace where nothing really bothers me. And I'm, yeah, I'm just really happy and kind of dating around, but not very seriously. I think if you listen to my episode on dating with intention, you'll know, I'm not here for, I'm not here for a casual runaround. I'm not, I'm not down to clown, as they say. I'm kind of just like, I value my time so much right now that I'm not really willing to let someone in unless they are the right person. And whether I found that right person yet or not, I do not know. So I guess that's what I'll say. And also, thank you to my ex-partners, because I'm very grateful to them. They really
去克服，不仅是关于过去的伴侣，也包括我自己的不安全感。我真的很高兴。我处于一种非常平静的状态，没有什么事真的能烦扰到我。我，是的，我真的很高兴，也在到处约会，但不是很严肃的那种。我想如果你听过我关于带着目的约会的节目，你就会知道，我不是来，我不是来随便玩玩的。正如他们所说，我可不是去瞎胡闹的。我差不多就是那种，我现在非常珍惜我的时间，以至于除非他们是对的人，否则我真的不愿意让某人走进我的生活。至于我是否已经找到了那个对的人，我不知道。所以我想这就是我要说的。还有，感谢我的前任们，因为我非常感激他们。他们真的
have, like, inspired a lot of the content on this show. It's interesting. This show, like, really started because of a breakup and then was really promoted, I guess. I really was inspired and motivated by another situation. And it's really refreshing to say now that I'm so glad I went through those experiences. And I'm so grateful to those people in a way that I don't think they'll ever know for not hurting me, but for just teaching me so much about myself and motivating me and inspiring me and really getting me to some points where I had to really sit down and think about my life. So if they're listening out there, big shout out to you guys. Big thank you. Alrighty. So next question, which was a little bit different, but it was just like, we want life updates. Where are you living right now? What are you doing? All right. So I get this question a lot. Someone asked me if I lived in Berlin the other day. I do not live in Berlin. Unfortunately, it does look amazing. I live in Sydney, Australia. I've lived here for two years, almost two years. And I actually live in a sharehouse. I live in a sharehouse with three amazing.
激发了这个节目的很多内容。这很有意思。这个节目，其实就是因为一次分手而开始的，然后又得到了真正的推广，我猜吧。我确实受到了另一种情况的启发和激励。现在能说“我很高兴自己经历了那些事情”真的是一种全新的体验。我对那些人充满了感激，这种感激或许他们永远不会知道，不是因为他们没有伤害我，而是因为他们教给了我那么多关于我自己的事情，激励了我、启发了我，并真正把我推向了某些时刻——在那些时刻，我不得不真正静下心来思考我的人生。所以如果他们正在收听的话，向你们大喊一声。非常感谢你们。好的。那么下一个问题，稍微有点不同，就是我们想要生活近况更新。你现在住在哪里？你在做什么？好吧。所以我经常遇到这个问题。前几天有人问我是不是住在柏林。我没有住在柏林。不幸的是，那里的确看起来棒极了。我住在澳大利亚悉尼。我在这里住了两年，快两年了。其实我住在合租房里。我和三个超棒的……
guys, big shout out to Tom Jack and Locky. They are amazing housemates and like genuinely such good people to live with. I think they have very much been like my rock. I would really advise that if you're in your 20s, you should live in a sharehouse. It really does teach you a lot. It is this like level of familiarity and like kind of family like kind of friends, kind of something else, relationship that we don't get to experience when we live at home with our parents or with our siblings or with the partner. So I, yeah, I still live in a sharehouse. I live in the attic of my sharehouse. There we go. So it's like really beautiful. I'm literally sitting here right now looking out my beautiful window. And I really wouldn't change it. I think that it's this way
男生一起合租，大声向汤姆、杰克和洛基（Tom, Jack, and Locky）致敬。他们是超级棒的室友，而且发自内心地是那种很好相处的人。我觉得他们很大程度上就像是我的精神支柱。我真心建议，如果你正处于二十岁，你应该去住合租房。它真的能教会你很多东西。这种亲密感和某种类似家庭、类似朋友、又类似其他什么的复合关系，是我们和父母、兄弟姐妹或伴侣住在一起时体验不到的。所以，是的，我仍然住在合租房里。我住在我们合租房的阁楼里。就是这样。所以感觉真的很美妙。我现在就坐在窗前，看着美丽的窗外。我真的不想改变这种生活方式。我觉得这种……
of living like it's interesting like I could definitely afford to live by myself or I could move out. But I enjoy this kind of communal name. in this communal way of living and I also like being able to sit down with someone at the end of the night and be like, okay, so what did you, what did you, what happened today? And, you know, what have you been thinking about? And like, do we want to go to the gym and just like have a bit of a chat? And it's actually just super rewarding and super valuable to me. I used to live in Canberra, grew up in like Melbourne slash Queensland, which if you're not from Australia, I feel like everyone knows were Melbourne and Queenslander. I don't know why I have to explain that. Like massive tourist hubs.
居住方式，这很有意思，我完全负担得起一个人住，或者搬出去。但我很享受这种群居的生活方式。我也喜欢在一天结束时能够和某人坐在一起聊天：“好吧，那你今天过得怎么样？发生了什么？”还有，“你最近在想些什么？我们要不要去健身房顺便聊聊天？”这其实对我来说超级有意义，也超级宝贵。我过去住在堪培拉，在墨尔本和昆士兰长大——如果你不是澳大利亚人，我觉得每个人都知道墨尔本和昆士兰是哪里，我不知道为什么我还要解释这个——就像是巨大的旅游中心。
And I recently also quit my nine to five job. So I used to work in like management consulting, I guess you would call it, particularly around mental health policy. So like advising government agencies and interest groups on how to better manage mental health in our society and what we needed to do and what systems we needed to change. But I recently quit to do the podcast full time, which is honestly such a blessing. I feel like this is such a gratitude episode where I'm like, thank you, thank you, thank you. But genuinely, without the listen, like without, oh my gosh, like without you guys tuning in, that wouldn't be my life.
我最近还辞掉了朝九晚五的工作。我以前从事管理咨询工作，我想你可以这么称呼它，特别是围绕心理健康政策的领域。比如为政府机构和利益集团提供咨询，告诉他们如何更好地管理我们社会的心理健康，我们需要做什么，以及我们需要改变哪些系统。但我最近辞职了，开始全职做播客，老实说这真是太幸运了。我觉得这期节目简直成了一期感恩专场，我一直在说“谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你们”。但说真的，如果没有大家的收听，如果没有，天哪，如果没有你们大家的收听，这绝不会成为我的生活。
And it was kind of rough trying to do, manage doing this podcast, which I love so deeply. and I would continue to do even if I couldn't do it full time. But managing that and like a 9 to 5 job and if you've ever worked in management consulting, my gosh, you will know it's never 9 to 5. It's like 8 to 7, sometimes longer. And then coming home and trying to write like a really deep and thoughtful episode and really apply it to my life. And I'm kind of glad that chapter is over.
而且，要一边平衡制作这个我深爱着的播客——即使不能全职做我也会继续做下去的播客——一边还要应付朝九晚五的工作，真的挺艰难的。如果你在管理咨询行业工作过，天哪，你就会知道那绝对不是朝九晚五。那是早上八点到晚上七点，有时甚至更久。然后拖着疲惫的身躯回家，还试图写出一期真正深刻、有思想、能真正应用到我生活中的节目。我其实挺高兴那个章节已经结束了。
But that is where I'm at right now. Someone asked what are my plans for the future? Oh my goodness. So many things. So many things. Oh, I, I feel like I can say it on here. So like, oh my gosh, maybe, hopefully my team doesn't like get mad at me. Shelby, if you're listening to this.
但这就是我目前的现状。有人问我未来的计划是什么？哦天哪。太多事情了。太多事情了。哦，我，我觉得我可以在这里说出来，所以，天哪，也许，希望我的团队不要生我的气。谢尔比（Shelby），如果你在听这个。
I'm so sorry. But, yeah, we're like in the process of like launching a Patreon, which is like something I've always really wanted to do. There are things that you guys ask me for a lot. One of them is like episode transcripts, Q&A slash like advice episodes. like a newsletter, book recommendations, like more of a community space. And that was something that I was really, like I had some goals for this year and that was on there to create a space for that to happen.
真的非常抱歉。但是，是的，我们正在筹备上线一个 Patreon 平台，这其实是我一直非常想做的事情。你们经常向我索要一些东西。其中之一就是节目文稿、问答/解答咨询环节、还有新闻邮件、书籍推荐，以及更多的社区空间。这是我真正想做的事——我今年定了一些目标，而建立一个能实现这些的空间就在其中。
So that's launching soon, you know, alongside that. Other things that you could maybe pick up and read. Obviously, we had the merch launching at the side of the year, but also there's a new line of merch coming out soon as well. and just actually like my plans for the future is to also go back to uni and get like a further qualification. This just seems like a great time and to do it in something different like either in journalism or even cognitive neuroscience. That's like an area of psychology that I find and even science that I find like super fascinating. So going and doing even further study, although I feel like I am still burnt out from like all my years at university.
所以这个很快就要上线了，你知道的，除此之外。还有其他一些你们可能可以买到并阅读的东西。显然我们在年初推出了周边商品，不过不久后也会有一系列新的周边商品推出。至于我未来的计划，其实还包括重返大学攻读一个更高的学位。现在感觉是个绝佳的时机，而且要攻读一个不同的领域，比如新闻学，甚至是认知神经科学。那是心理学中我发现超级迷人的一个领域，甚至是科学领域也是如此。所以我想去进行更深入的学习，尽管我觉得自己已经被多年的大学生活折腾得精疲力竭了。
and I'm also traveling a bunch. So I just got back from London. I was in Indonesia for a little while and then coming to L.A. soon and then to New York. So if any of you want to meet up, come and get a coffee with me. I love meeting people. We can just like have a yarn, have a chat about whatever's going on in our lives. So yeah, those are my plans. It feels like so big.
而且我最近也在四处旅行。我刚从伦敦回来，在印度尼西亚待了一小段时间，接下来很快要去洛杉矶，然后去纽约。所以如果你们当中有谁想见个面，快来找我喝杯咖啡吧。我喜欢结识新朋友。我们可以随便聊聊天，聊聊我们生活中正在发生的事情。所以，是的，这就是我的计划。感觉格局好宏大。
Like, yeah, so big. But I'm just like so excited for this next chapter. I feel like if this is as good as it gets, I'm so happy where I am right now. So I'm just looking forward to what's coming and like just making good content, bringing on really good guess. That kind of leads into this next question is, what topics have you not covered that you really want to? I don't know if you guys know this,
就像，是的，好宏大。但我真的超级期待这个新篇章。我觉得如果这就是生活能达到的最好状态，我对目前的现状已经感到非常开心了。所以我很期待接下来的发展，以及创作出优质的内容、邀请真正棒的嘉宾。这也顺理成章地引出了下一个问题：有哪些主题是你还没涉猎但非常想做的？我不知道你们知不知道，
but I have a massive, like, master list of over 100 topics that I really want to do. And every time someone messages me an idea, I also have another list for that that I will sometimes pick from. But let me see what I have right now. I've got my phone up. Oh my goodness. So I'm there's so good. This one that is actually coming up. So the impact of trauma on our bodies, how to be completely unique. That's actually coming out next week. Oh, is pretty privilege real. The psychology of internalized misogyny. I really want to do that. I feel like that would be so fascinating, the psychology of attractiveness, body dysmorphia, the science behind the ick. I also want to do, I think, a bit more on certain mental health conditions.
我有一个庞大的总清单，上面有100多个我真的很想做的主题。每当有人发给我一个好点子，我也会为它单列一个清单，有时我会从里面挑选。让我看看我手头现在有什么。我把手机拿出来了。哦天哪。它们太棒了。其中有一个很快就要推出了：创伤对我们身体的影响，如何变得完全独一无二。这个其实下周就要播出了。哦，外表特权是真的吗？内化厌女症的心理学。我真的很想做这个。我觉得这会非常迷人：吸引力的心理学、身体变形恐惧症（body dysmorphia）、“下头”（the ick）背后的科学。我还想做，我觉得，更多关于特定心理健康状况的内容。
I think that I shy away from them sometimes because I do want to bring on someone who specialises. Like, for example, I get a lot of interest in discussions around ADHD and obviously I, you know, know what ADHD is and I studied ADHD and it was part of like what I learned about but I really want like a psychiatrist or someone who specializes in that area to come on the same with trauma as well. I think trauma is something that we can all understand on an anecdotal level and perhaps if you studied psychology on a biological level or a psychological level but in some ways you want to get deeper into some of the research. So I actually have a guest coming on for that. Oh my goodness. One actually that I really am excited to do, which is so different, is the
我觉得我有时会有所回避，因为我确实想邀请一位专家来做嘉宾。例如，我收到很多关于讨论 ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍）的兴趣，当然我，你知道的，我知道什么是 ADHD，我也研究过 ADHD，这是我所学知识的一部分，但我真的希望有一位精神科医生或该领域的专家来做客，创伤话题也是如此。我认为创伤是我们在轶事层面上都能理解的东西，如果你学过心理学，可能在生物学或心理学层面上也能理解，但在某些方面，你需要更深入地研究一些研究成果。所以其实我为此请了一位嘉宾。哦天哪。还有一个我真的非常期待去做的、非常不同的主题，那就是……
healing power of nature. I don't know. I've been going through this phase recently where I've been reading so many amazing books that really promote nature as a form of therapy in some ways. And I think it is still quite a rudimentary scientific theory, but there are ideas of like, what's it called forest bathing in Japan? And this amazing book called, rewilding that I think is fantastic. And I really want to bring that discussion to the show. And I don't think it's controversial to say that nature has such a profound impact on our bodies and our minds and our anxiety and our stress levels.
大自然的治愈力量。我不知道。我最近经历了一个阶段，读了那么多精彩的书籍，它们在某种程度上极力推崇大自然作为一种治疗形式。我认为这在科学上仍然是一个相当初步的理论，但有一些概念，比如日本的森林浴叫什么来着？还有一本叫《重野化》（rewilding）的神奇书籍，我觉得太棒了。我真的很想把这个讨论带到节目中来。而且我认为说大自然对我们的身体、大脑、焦虑和压力水平有着深远的影响，这绝不是什么有争议的观点。
So that's one that I'm really excited about. And then this one as well, which I'm like, I think I might do with the Patreon thing, which is like a live episode, like a call in. I don't know if anyone would want to do that, but I think that would be really fun. I just like to think of like new ways that you can kind of connect with the content, right? And new ways that we're able to really make these ideas and theories in psychology more accessible. So, yeah, those are the topics I really want to do. I would also, like I said, love to bring my best friend Aaron back on.
所以这是让我非常兴奋的一个主题。还有这个，我觉得我可能会在 Patreon 上结合这个做点东西，比如做一期直播节目，类似于连线互动那种。我不知道有没有人想参与，但我觉得那一定会超级有趣。我只是喜欢去想一些能与内容建立连接的新方式，对吧？以及寻找能让心理学这些观点和理论变得更加平易近人的新方法。所以，是的，这些就是我真的很想做的主题。而且就像我说的，我很乐意把我的好闺蜜埃琳（Erin）请回来。
She's a champion. You should go and listen to that episode, that 9 to 5 episode. Like, I wish all of you had a best friend as amazing. her. She's like such a legend. So I think that is, yeah, those are my, the ones I really want to do. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
她是位冠军。你们真该去听听那一期，那一期“9到5”。真的，我希望你们所有人都能有一个这么棒的闺蜜。她简直就是个传奇。所以我觉得，对，这就是我真正想做的那些。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中构建心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人展开对话，带大家拨开那些充斥在健康产业中的不切实际
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经深信植物油具有天生的炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即英文单词“T-W-O”加上“Percent”，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客
or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
或各大播客平台收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不在乎黑人时发生的事？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回望》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. clearly, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）做客的节目，他大谈特谈80年代的快克可卡因。显然，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊当年的快克，不过想让大家知道的是。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆到台面上来了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客上收听《回望》（Look Back at It）
or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
或各大播客平台收听。欢迎来到我的新播客节目《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会深陷追逐的过程之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们却还在盲目追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是说你做个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
因为那是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我的新播客《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way），由我基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）带你探讨关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标的真实对话。
Open your free. iHeartRadio app search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开免费的iHeartRadio App，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她言辞中的巨大漏洞。这引发了一场长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars. were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男性：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这里是《情网难逃》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。这件事还没完。直到亚利桑那州伸张正义。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听《情网难逃》（Love Trap）播客。
Okay, so those are like some of the personal questions around like me in my life and the podcast. But as always, we've got to do a bit of the psychology. So I thought what we could do to kind of like end this like 100th special edition episode was like, a bonus lining round of advice questions. I get, like I said before, so many people asking me for advice on their life and I don't tend to answer them because I find sometimes that could be a bit odd like I'm, you know, I don't know, I feel a bit strange like I don't want to give you the wrong advice because I don't really know you. So if you have ever sent me a DM and I haven't responded, that's probably why I do still think it's valuable to share and I do
好了，这些是关于我和我的生活以及播客的一些个人问题。但和往常一样，我们得聊聊心理学。所以我想，为了给这期第一百集特别纪念版节目收尾，我们可以进行一轮趣味快问快答式的建议环节。正如我之前所说，有太多人向我寻求生活上的建议，而我往往不会回答，因为我有时觉得这有点奇怪，你知道的，我不知道，我感觉有点怪异，我不想给你错误的建议，因为我其实并不了解你。所以，如果你曾经给我发过私信而我没有回复，那可能就是这个原因。不过我依然觉得分享这些很有价值，而且我
read a lot of them, but I think there is this weird thing with social media sometimes, and even at this level, where you have to kind of respect the fact that you probably, you don't want to insert yourself or promise someone's support if you don't know them, because it can become a bit of a strange relationship, especially if like you're not their therapist. But this is like some general questions that I get a lot that I was like, let's just do it. I maybe I'll make a full episode about them, but let's do like some lightning round advice. So the first one is advice on regretting life choices, question mark. Okay, I think that regret is inevitable in some sense. Like, there are always going to be things that we question and things that we are unsure whether we
确实读了很多私信，但我觉得社交媒体上有时存在一种奇怪的现象，即使到了我这个层面，你也必须尊重这样一个事实：如果你不了解对方，你大概不应该强行介入或承诺给予某人支持，因为这可能会变成一种奇怪的关系，尤其是当你并非他们的治疗师时。不过这里有一些我经常收到的普遍问题，我想：那就做吧。也许我会专门做一期节目来探讨它们，但现在让我们来做一轮快问快答式的建议。所以第一个问题是：关于对生活选择感到后悔的建议，问号。好吧，我认为在某种意义上，后悔是不可避免的。比如，总会有一些事情让我们产生质疑，让我们不确定自己是否
made the right decision. And I think that's because our brains in a lot of ways want to be able to understand and make sense from the nonsense or make sense of, the story that we're telling ourselves. And if the story we're telling ourselves doesn't line up with our goals, we may experience some cognitive dissonance, and that results in regret. I also think that regret is, in part, evolutionary as well. We want to learn from past mistakes, but obviously what we deem as a mistake is highly subjective, and it's really based on your perception. So that's something that I think we need to realize. What you think is, what you think of as regret is not always something that you should regret because I think everything brings you
做出了正确的决定。我认为这是因为我们的大脑在很多方面都希望能够理解并从混乱中理清头绪，或者理清我们对自己讲述的故事。如果我们对自己讲述的故事与我们的目标不一致，我们可能会经历一些认知失调，而这就会导致后悔。我也认为，从某种程度上讲，后悔也是一种进化机制。我们希望从过去的错误中吸取教训，但显然，我们认为什么是错误是高度主观的，它很大程度上基于你的认知。所以这是我们需要意识到的一点。你认为是、你所认为的后悔，并不总是你应该后悔的事，因为我认为每件事都会把你带到
to the place that you need to be. That is not a highly psychological theory. That's just a personal opinion. I, and also an anecdotal one, I look back on my life and I think all those things that, you know, I regretted, I regretted saying yes to that job. I regretted saying no to that opportunity. I regret dating that person. I regret not moving out faster. I regret all these different things. everything, the timing of everything is so, so particular. And if certain things had not happened at certain points, there are things that you would have missed out on that I think you would equally regret having missed out on, if that makes sense. Also, there is a study that I quote, and I talk about a lot. It's my favorite ever research paper ever, ever published. And it basically
你需要去的地方。这并不是一个高度理论化的心理学理论。这只是一种个人观点。而且也是一种基于个人经历的看法，我回首自己的人生，心想所有那些我曾后悔过的事情——我后悔答应了那份工作。我后悔拒绝了那个机会。我后悔和那个人约会。我后悔没有早点搬出去。我后悔所有这些不同的事情。每一件事，每一件事的时机都是如此之巧妙。如果某些事情在某些节点没有发生，你就会错过一些事情，而我认为，如果你错过了这些事情，你同样也会感到后悔，如果这说得通的话。此外，还有一项我经常引用的研究。这是我最喜欢的、有史以来发表过最棒的研究论文。它基本上
examined the chances that we will regret a decision in the future. And the research is basically concluded that you are way more likely to regret something that you didn't do than something that you did. So I think that if you're having that regret around actions that you did take, it's very likely that if you hadn't done them, there was this whole other level of, there's a whole of kind of deep sea of regret that you would have fallen into anyhow. I think it's also around dealing with the negative emotions associated with it. Practice self-forgiveness. Practice self-compassion. recognize that everyone in life has something that they regret. Everyone has said something that they didn't mean.
探讨了我们在未来对某个决定感到后悔的概率。该研究的基本结论是：你更有可能对你没做过的事感到后悔，而不是对你做过的事感到后悔。所以我想，如果你对你确实采取的行动感到后悔，很有可能如果你当初没有这样做，你将会坠入另一片更深、更广阔的后悔之海。我认为这也关乎如何应对与之相关的负面情绪。练习自我宽恕。练习自我同情。认识到生活中的每个人都有后悔的事。每个人都说过言不由衷的话。
Everyone has acted in a way that they didn't like everyone. Every single person on this planet, nobody is perfect. So I think when we recognize experiences as universal, it takes away a lot of the shame and a lot of that negative emotion. So there you go. Lightning round of advice. The next question is, why do I get attached so quickly? Okay. I'm going to have four answers. First one, attachment style, easy-peasy. If you are someone who is anxiously attached, that is a massive, I would say, determinate. Fantasy bonding. You fall in love with the idea of someone and the what-if rather than their actual character traits and whether or not they are good for you. I would also say unrealistic expectations. And part of that is unresolved emotional trauma. For example,
每个人都做过自己不喜欢的事，每个人都是。地球上的每一个人，没有人是完美的。所以我觉得，当我们把这些经历视为普遍现象时，就会消解掉很多羞耻感和负面情绪。好了，这就是快问快答环节的建议。下一个问题是：为什么我总是那么容易动情？好吧。我将给出四个答案。第一个，依恋类型，很简单。如果你是一个焦虑型依恋的人，我可以说，这是一个巨大的决定性因素。幻想式依恋。你爱上的是某个人的幻想以及“如果……会怎样”的假设，而不是他们的真实性格特征以及他们是否适合你。我还要说的是，不切实际的期望。而其中一部分原因则是未解开的情感创伤。例如，
If you have felt that you have to fall really hard really quickly because otherwise they will walk away, that might be a massive predictor. If you have felt in the past as if you were not desirable and you were not loved or you weren't lovable, when someone does begin to show you that affection, sometimes it can be really overwhelming and your brain almost reacts like it's having an overdose of oxytocin and dopamine and all these feelings. I am someone who really follows the philosophy of go out and live boldly and obviously it's not great to get attached too quickly and get your heart broken, but I think it's a lot better than never feeling anything, to be honest. I was having this discussion with a friend the other day and I was like, I would much rather fall head over heels than be guarded. But I do know that it's not exactly ideal.
如果你曾觉得，你必须非常迅速且深深地爱上对方，否则他们就会离开，这可能是一个巨大的预测指标。如果你在过去曾感到自己并不具有吸引力，不被爱，或者不讨人喜欢，当有人开始向你展现这种喜爱时，有时它会让你感到不知所措，你的大脑几乎会产生一种催产素和多巴胺过量以及所有这些感觉的反应。我是一个真正遵循“走出去，大胆生活”哲学的人，虽然太快动情并心碎并不是什么好事，但老实说，我觉得这总比从未有过任何感觉要好得多。我前几天还在和一位朋友讨论这件事，我说，我宁愿疯狂坠入爱河，也不愿有所防备。但我确实知道这并非理想状态。
So I would say really set up clear boundaries with your. yourself around knowing if this person is right for you. I think the biggest problem in the major consideration is when your judgment is clouded by these feelings such that you ignore things that will inevitably create havoc or not be good for your relationship. So really maybe create a checklist or some guidelines that you created before you went out and started dating again or before you met this person around what you're actually looking for, what your expectations are and whether they are meeting them. All right, next question is, should I try dating apps? Yes and no. I would say you should give it a go. Just be aware that like,
所以我想说，真要在自己身上设定清晰的界限，去了解这个人是否真的适合你。我认为最大的问题和主要考量在于，当你的判断力被这些感觉蒙蔽时，你会忽略那些不可避免会制造混乱或对你的关系不利的事情。所以，或许可以列一个清单，或者设定一些准则——这是你在重新开始约会之前或遇到这个人之前就制定好的——关于你真正在寻找什么，你的期望是什么，以及他们是否达到了这些要求。好的，下一个问题是：我应该尝试约会软件吗？答案是肯定的，也是否定的。我会说，你应该去尝试一下。只是要意识到，
I would say from personal experience, this is also just personal experience. It's very hard to know what someone's actually looking for. And I think also dating in the age of digital technology means that we make a lot of snap instantaneous decisions based on pitches and very instant stimuli that might actually mean you're discrediting or rejecting someone not based on personality. It doesn't mean you need to date everyone you see on a dating app, but I think go into it with an open mind. On the other hand, I would say have a break every now and again. Sometimes you can just get like overwhelmed by the choice overload on a dating app and
从个人经验来看，这也是纯粹的个人经验，很难知道某人究竟在寻找什么。而且我认为，在数字技术时代的约会也意味着，我们根据照片和非常即时的刺激做出了很多仓促、瞬间的决定，这实际上可能意味着你仅仅因为外表而否定或拒绝了某人，而这与个性无关。这并不意味着你需要和约会软件上看到的每个人约会，但我认为去的时候要抱着开放的心态。另一方面，我想说的是，每隔一段时间要休息一下。有时你只是会被约会软件上过载的选择弄得不知所措，
can kind of get a little bit addicted to like the fast-paced, very immediate nature of like always being able to find someone to like go on a date with or hook up with or even like get into a relationship with. So approach it with caution. That would be my advice. How to stop associating your self-worth with how much we produce slash how we perform at work. I'm also going to include like school there. I think this question around what is my worth if I'm not productive. is a massive problem for this generation. We have been really socially ingrained and scolded and taught and conditioned that everything we're doing, everything we should be doing is towards an outcome and an output.
并且可能会对那种快节奏、极其直接的模式产生一点点依赖，比如总是能找到人去约会、发生关系，甚至是建立恋爱关系。所以要谨慎对待。这就是我的建议。如何停止将自我价值与我们的产出多少以及我们在工作中的表现挂钩？我这里也要把学校算进去。我认为围绕“如果我不高产，我的价值何在”这一问题，是这一代人面临的巨大问题。我们在社会层面上已经被深深地灌输、指责、教导和规训，认为我们所做的每一件事、应该做的每一件事，都是为了一个结果和产出。
If you are not productive, you are not worthwhile. I would say find joy and find time to do things slowly. For example, when you're cooking dinner, give yourself an extra, 10 minutes to just enjoy the process. Once a week, plan out an activity that is not time-based, that is not productive, that you just want to do. Honestly, I asked myself this question the other day, how many times during the week do I actually do something that isn't based on output or like meeting some goal? And I would even say like going out for dinner like with your friends, like that is still like productivity because you want to see your friends, you tick it off a list, whatever. Like,
如果你没有产出，你就没有价值。我想说的是，去寻找慢节奏做事的乐趣和时间。例如，当你做晚饭时，给自己多留10分钟来享受这个过程。每周规划一次与时间无关、与产出无关、仅仅是你自己想做的活动。老实说，我前几天就在问自己这个问题：在一周里，我究竟有多少次是在做一件完全不以产出或达成某种目标为基础的事情？甚至可以说，就像和朋友出去吃晚饭，那其实也算是一种产出，因为你想见你的朋友，你从清单上划掉了一项，诸如此类。就像，
I really think you need to rest your identity more on what your values are and what your beliefs are and what you enjoy doing, your passions and your hobbies, regardless of whether you're good at them. Like, I love people who are bad at their hobbies. I'm bad at my hobbies. They shouldn't, you know, they shouldn't be for, they shouldn't be like an efficiency meter. Like, they should just be for fun. So I would say really have a solid think about what your values are, but then also spend time doing something that you want to do just because you want to do it, even if you're bad at it. Because I think that really untrains our brain to only see our worth as what we produce. Okay, next question. So many good ones. I'm obsessed with these. I should do this more often.
我真的认为你需要将你的身份更多地建立在你的价值观、你的信仰、你喜欢做的事情、你的热情和爱好上，而不管你是否擅长它们。比如，我喜欢那些爱好做得不好的人。我自己做爱好就不擅长。它们不应该，你知道的，它们不应该变成效率的衡量标准。它们应该纯粹为了好玩。所以我认为，真正好好思考一下你的价值观是什么，然后花时间做一件你想做的事，仅仅因为你想做，哪怕你做得不好。因为我认为这真的能训练我们的摆脱那种只把自我价值视为产出的思维模式。好了，下一个问题。有这么多好问题。我简直对这些着迷了。我应该更经常做这个。
Oh, this one's quite sad, but I do want to talk about this. So I'm feeling. really upset about how my body looks. Tips for building self-confidence. Okay, first of all, social media is your enemy here. I need you to go on social media, either delete the app, and I mean Instagram, TikTok, primarily those two, or deliberately unfollow everyone that is making you feel that way. I think it's very easy to jump online and have a million different examples of how our body should look like, of how our face should look like, of whether we should get
哦，这个问题有点悲伤，但我确实想聊聊。所以我对自己的外表感到非常沮丧。建立自信的技巧。好吧，首先，社交媒体在这里是你的敌人。我需要你打开社交媒体，要么卸载应用——我说的是Instagram和TikTok，主要是这两个——要么刻意取消关注所有让你产生这种感觉的人。我觉得很容易在网上看到成千上万种关于我们的身材应该是什么样的、我们的脸应该长成什么样的、我们是否应该去注射
filler of whether we should wear different clothes or whether we should lose weight. And I think removing that as a trigger is perhaps the biggest way that you can improve your self-confidence. But I think whilst you remove that trigger, you also need to do the deep work. I would say therapy is amazing for this, but also buy, there's like just very simple things. Like buy clothes that you feel comfortable in, wear clothes that you feel comfortable in, do things that you feel comfortable doing. Surround yourself with people who do not have confidence. conversations around body image. I mean the people who you sit down with and they're like, oh my God, I feel so fat. Or like, oh my God, like my thighs look enormous and they're like, oh, I can't
填充物、我们是否应该穿不同的衣服或者我们是否应该减肥的不同范例。而我认为消除这个诱发因素，或许是你提升自信的最大途径。但我觉得，在消除这个诱发因素的同时，你也需要做深层的功课。我会说治疗对这方面非常有用，但也可以买一些，比如非常简单的事情。比如买让你感到舒适的衣服，穿让你感到舒适的衣服，做让你觉得舒服的事。让自己身边的朋友都不会围绕
eat that. Like I'm going to put on so much weight. You don't need those people in your life. And if you do want to see them, don't see them in a context of like exercise or food. Or I would say like do something that's a neutral activity. I would also say this is a really weird one but find ways to move your body that isn't about exercise it's just about being connected to your body so for me that's like having this thing that i call a crazy dance where i just like put music on in my room and just like let my body do what it wants to do it always makes me feel more confident it leaves me feeling better but like yoga is a really good one or just like anything that gets you moving swimming in the ocean, just letting the waves like take your body where it wants to go.
身材体相进行自信心对话。我的意思是那些和你坐在一起然后说：“天哪，我觉得自己好胖”或者“天哪，我的大腿看起来好粗”，然后她们说“哦，我不能吃这个，我会长好多肉”的人。你的生活中不需要这样的人。如果你确实想见他们，也不要在一个充满运动或食物的语境下去见他们。或者我会说，去做一些中立的活动。我还要说，这是一个非常奇怪的方法，但去寻找那些不关乎锻炼、只关乎与你的身体建立连接的身体活动方式。对我和来说，就是做一件我称之为“疯狂舞蹈”的事情，我只是在房间里放起音乐，然后让我的身体做它想做的事。这总能让我感到更加自信，让我感觉更好。不过像瑜伽就是一个很好的选择，或者只是任何能让你动起来的事情，在海里游泳，任由海浪带走你的身体去它想去的地方。
I think it's about reconnecting with your body and recognizing that your body is, it's just a vessel for a lot more beautiful, beautiful things about you. It's just a vessel for your love, for your kindness, for your amazing traits and personality. I know it's so stereotypical, but personality really is the most worthwhile thing. Okay, I'm going to do one more question because I'm realizing that we're, have gone for a while. Okay, what advice would you give to a heartbroken girl?
我认为这关乎重新与你的身体建立连接，并认识到你的身体，它只是承载你身上更多美丽、美好事物的容器。它只是你对爱的容器、对善良的容器、是你惊艳的特质和个性的容器。我知道这听起来很陈词滥调，但个性确实是最有价值的东西。好吧，我还要回答最后一个问题，因为我意识到我们已经聊了很久了。好吧，你会给一个心碎的女孩什么建议？
How do you get over someone? I think channel, my biggest piece of advice, and this is something I do after every breakup, end of a situation, whatever, is channel that negative energy, that grief, that sadness into something creative and productive that is solely tied to your actions. So, for example, I started this podcast, but also I, like, took up painting after a breakup. Like, I took up, like, this really amazing journaling practice after something ended recently. Those kinds of activities, or another one is like one of my friends took up, like, cycling or rock climbing. Find ways to reconnect with a part of you that they don't know, that they've never touched, that they will never get to experience.
如何放下一个人？我认为，我最好的建议——这也是我在每次分手、每段关系结束等等之后都会做的事情——是将那种负面能量、那种悲伤、那种难过转化为某种具有创造性和高产的事情，并且这完全取决于你自己的行动。比如，我创办了这个播客，但我也在分手后开始学画画。比如，在最近某段关系结束后，我开始进行非常棒的写日记实践。诸如此类的活动，或者另一个例子是我的一个朋友开始练习骑自行车或攀岩。去寻找那些与他们不了解、从未触及、也永远无法体验到的你的那一部分重新建立连接的方法。
I think a big part about at the end of a relationship, is questions around self-worth and questions around, am I good enough? Will I find someone better? And who am I without this person? I promise that time heals all wounds. And it's just one foot in front of the other. Every day it will get easier. Spend as much time as you can doing the things you love that make you feel like yourself.
我认为在一段感情结束时，很大一部分问题是关于自我价值的质疑，以及诸如“我够好吗？我会找到更好的人吗？没有这个人我是谁”之类的疑问。我向你们保证，时间会治愈一切创伤。这只是迈出一步，然后又一步。每一天都会变得容易一些。尽可能多地花时间做那些你热爱的事情，那些能让你做回自己的事情。
And then one day it's so annoying to say this, but you just wake up. up and you're just free. Like you just feel better and you're just, you're not worried about them anymore. You couldn't care less if they're dating someone, what they're doing. You're just like, happy to be you and happy to be alive. And I think also, it's about, like, you, if you want to find someone else, you will find someone else. But the most valuable relationship you'll ever have is with yourself. So, especially as, you know, this is a podcast for people in their 20s, I'm assuming, most of us are in our 20s, you have so much time to like establish the best kind of connection with yourself. You have so much time to really build that foundation. And I think a lot of people
然后有一天——说出这话真的很烦人——但你一觉醒来，你突然就自由了。就像你突然感觉好多了，你不再为他们担心了。你根本不在乎他们在和谁约会，在做什么。你只是，很高兴成为你自己，很高兴活着。而且我也认为，这关乎，如果你想找到另一个人，你会找到另一个人的。但你拥有的最重要的关系是你自己。所以，尤其是当，你知道的，这是一个面向20多岁人群的播客，我猜我们大多数人都在20多岁，你有如此多的时间来与自己建立最美好的连接。你有如此充裕的时间去真正打好这个基础。而且我认为很多人
don't take the time to do that because they use new relationships to heal their last ones. I was someone who did that. And then like this last like I think, oh yeah, like this last like four months, I, like, really took time to just be like, okay, you know, something ended at the end of last year. Let's really just, like, spend some time healing from that and pushing forward and just reconnecting with yourself. Also, get out into nature. I saw this, like, TikTok that was like, the situation ship was so bad that we had to reconnect with nature. And I was like, oh, my goodness, that has been me. But honestly, go and find, like, your closest swimming hole or your closest beach or your closest pool of any sort, a body of water heals everything. That would be my advice.
并没有花时间去做这件事，因为他们用新的恋情来疗愈上一段恋情。我曾经就是那样的人。然后就像这最后，我想，哦，对，就像这过去的四个月里，我真的花时间去静一静，心想：好吧，你知道的，去年年底一段关系结束了。让我们真正花点时间从中疗愈，继续前行，并重新与自己建立连接。此外，去大自然中走走。我看到过这样一个TikTok，上面说：这个暧昧对象太糟糕了，以至于我们不得不重新回归大自然。当时我想，哦天哪，那不就是我吗？但老实说，去找找你附近能游泳的地方、或者最近的海滩、或者任何形式的水池，水体能治愈一切。这就是我的建议。
And I will say heartbreak, there is reverence in heartbreak. There is beauty. There is a sacredness to heartbreak. It really reveals the deepest parts of your emotions and the deepest parts of your insecurities. And it's very rare that we get a peer that deeply into what's going on in our soul and what's going on into our mind. So take it as an opportunity. I would. wouldn't be where I am without the three, you know, biggest heartbreaks of my 20s. And I'm so grateful for them, like I said earlier. So I would say take what you can from it and leave the rest behind and just know that time will heal or wounds.
我要说的是，心碎，心碎之中有着敬畏。有着美感。心碎有着一种神圣性。它真正揭示了你情感中最深的部分以及你内心中最深的 insecurities（不安全感）。我们极少有机会能如此深刻地审视自己灵魂深处和内心深处发生了什么。所以把它当作一个机会吧。如果没有我20多岁时经历的这三次最严重的心碎，我不会走到今天。就像我刚才说的，我非常感激它们。所以我想说，从中学你能吸收的，把剩下的抛在脑后，只要知道时间会治愈所有创伤。
I think that's all we have time for. I just want to say again, thank you firstly for all your questions. But secondly, for all of your support. I am beyond grateful in a way I can never express that people want to listen to this show. I cannot believe that I've made 100 episodes and I wouldn't have done that without some of the amazing feedback and support from, not even the people just from day one, but the people who started listening six months ago, three months ago, even if this is like your first episode, thank you. Thank you for deciding to listen this far. As always, if you do feel called to do so,
我想我们今天的时间就到这里。我只想再次表达感谢，首先感谢大家提出的所有问题。其次，感谢你们所有的支持。我内心的感激之情无以言表，感谢大家想要收听这个节目。我简直不敢相信我已经制作了100期节目，如果没有来自大家的惊人反馈和支持，我根本无法做到这一点——甚至不仅是那些从第一天起就支持的人，还有那些在六个月前、三个月前开始收听的人，甚至如果这是你的第一期节目，谢谢你。谢谢你决定收听这么久。和往常一样，如果你确实觉得想这么做的话，
please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. And follow me at that psychology podcast. on Instagram. You can watch some of my video content over there, but also you can send in some episodes suggestions, be part of the community, know what's going on. Happy 100th. I cannot believe it. And just thank you for tuning in. My gosh, I'm just like fawning over everyone who's listening right now. But yeah, I'm really grateful. So thanks for joining us for this episode. We will be back on Friday for our regularly scheduled content. Hey, what's good, y'all?
请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。并在Instagram上关注我@thatpsychology.podcast。你可以在那里观看我的一些视频内容，也可以发送一些节目建议，成为社区的一员，了解最新动态。第一百集快乐！我简直不敢相信。感谢你们的收听。天哪，我现在简直对所有正在收听的人崇拜得不行。不过，是的，我真的很感激。所以感谢大家加入我们本期节目。我们将在周五带着常规排期的内容回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
欢迎收听《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way）。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中构建心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
收听《2%》。即“TWO%”。可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。在《回望》（Look Back at It）播客中……对于1979年来说，那对我和说是一个大时刻。84年对我来说很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·杰（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何熬过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. You get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我觉得没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听《回望》（Look Back at It）。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。